ni mayor ni leo penn ese es el mensaje
de los estudiantes que se reunieron
frente a la universidad parís uno
sorbona ocupada desde el miércoles los
manifestantes se enfrentaron a la
policía que usó gases lacrimógenos para
dispersarlos sin provocar ningún herido
último en la segunda vuelta a los
clasificados son macrón que tiene un
programa de derecha y marie le pen que
tiene un programa de extrema derecha y
no son programas que respetan mucho a
los estudiantes los jóvenes denuncian
una campaña política que deja de lado
los temas sociales y medioambientales en
la primera vuelta el 40 por ciento de
los menores de 34 años se abstuvieron
los que votaron mayoritariamente
eligieron al running - y se encuentran
hoy frente a un dilema en austin
situación como con eso electro hoy
tenemos una situación en la que decían
votantes de jean-luc mélenchon la mitad
no se pronuncia votan blanco o se
abstiene 30 votarían por emanuel macro
ni 20 a favor de marín depende así que
vemos que este grupo de votantes está
dividido no como bien que se juntan
directo a que divide una parte de los
jóvenes indecisos señala la necesidad de
bloquear
extrema derecha incluso si eso significa
votar por macul
yo creo que si la gente no se motiva
para ir a votar si los que se abstienen
no van a votar si la gente que se sintió
decepcionada por la primera ronda no va
a votar entonces marine le pen tiene sus
posibilidades de ganar esa es la razón
por la que debemos empujar nos unos a
otros y tomar esta elección en nuestras
manos y contrarrestar a marín
dependiendo del exoma elección tras
elección la candidata de extrema derecha
estrecha la distancia con sus rivales
por lo que es incierto lo que pase el
próximo 24 de abril durante el balotaje